- Let's start with Christine.
I believe Christine, you had your hand
very patiently raised last time.
So let's start with you.
And a reminder we-
- Yeah.
- We are recording this session
as I put the last one on LinkedIn.
So, (chuckles) it's gonna happen again.
So by participating, you know,
that that might happen not
you know, just kind of our,
our release form, implicitly.
All right, Christine, go ahead.
- Sounds good, thanks for the great memory
and of course like everyone here, big fan.
I've been a user for quite some time.
My question for you is,
in times where you're
trying to make a decision
where the answer isn't super clear,
it's a really tough choice.
Whether this is deciding
what major you wanna have in college?
When you wanna stay in
a job or leave a job?
What are values or a piece of advice
that you turn to in making
these types of decisions?
- Yeah that's a good,
that's a good question.
I do feel like you know,
this decision-making
is one of these things that no one
really explicitly in any way teaches you
or gives you even frames of reference.
I heard a quote recently
which I really liked,
and I do think this is
part of my life philosophy,
I'd like to believe.
Which is,
"There's oftentimes no right decision
but you can make the decision right."
So once you've committed to a decision,
I do think that it is and,
my mind does tend to work this way.
I tend to convince myself
that I made the best possible decision
and then I do what I can
to make the decision right.
You know, first of all,
if you're always second
guessing the decision
by definition, whatever decision you made
will almost, you're making it wrong
cause you're always looking at
what the alternative path could have been.
So that's my first advice is always
have an attitude of
making the decision right.
No matter what you're doing,
whether it's a job or a major,
or choosing a partner.
Just think day in, day out,
what can I do today to make
this, make things better,
to make a positive dent in the universe,
to learn more, to get excited about it.
When you're at the point
of making a decision,
I tend to you know, do my best to just
do a fairly rational
decision tree, if I can.
Now I will say and I do, I do do that.
You know, I've often
joked that people know me
for my math videos and science
videos and other videos,
but I've also wanted to make like,
things like a dating video.
I've met friends who might be with someone
and I'm like, well, are you
going to marry that person?
And they're like, well no, probably not.
And I was like, then why are you?
Like every day that you delay this,
you're just making the pain larger
in some future state.
And if you do the decision tree,
it's not a complicated one.
You're like less pain
now versus ignoring it
and making more pain in the future.
So I do recommend taking a lens of that.
I also think,
making decisions that are not just
in your best interest but
making decisions that are,
that you're truly trying to make it
an interest of anyone, everyone involved
in the system, you know.
I try not to judge people,
but when I do judge (chuckles) people,
I judge them on the decisions they make
that the consequences for them,
were they looking at the
consequences of the system,
not just the consequences for themselves?
I mean going back to the whole,
the whole dating example,
I've seen people.
I'd say not to judge but sometimes
selfishly stay in something that lowers
the other person's option value over time.
Which I think is actually
very, very selfish
that's the times I've most
harshly judged people.
Although I try not to judge, you know,
we all have our flaws.
I do think that intuition,
intuition sometimes,
we don't take it that seriously
because it's kind of like, oh,
you're just going off of gut.
I do remind folks that your gut actually
does have a lot of neurons.
So your gut is kind of a mini brain.
Your gut actually has more neurons
than some animals have in their brains
but on top of that.
You know, in our actual brains
not just even our gut brains,
we have a hundred billion neurons.
One of the critiques of machine learning
is that it can come up with insights
but you can't explain why that neural net
is coming, is saying that that is a dog
and that is not a dog.
I think our human brains are similar
is that it can, it is a
big neural net and it can.
What intuition really is,
is it's your neural net
telling you this is a
dog and that's not a dog
but you can't exactly explain why.
Of course I can explain why
something might be a dog or not.
But why this is the right major?
Why this is the right career?
Why this might be the right partner?
Sometimes I do think, is a gut thing.
I've got to say, last time I talked
about solving hard problems
and sometimes you just have
to look at the problem
and engage with the problem
and then sleep on it.
And then the next day all of a sudden,
you've delegated to your subconscious mind
and it's been churning on that problem
while you're sleeping.
And then when you wake up, I found this,
sometimes you can solve the
problem, almost magically.
I found the same thing
with major decisions.
I don't fret too much about them.
I will, I will think about them.
I will do the whole decision tree thing.
I'll oftentimes meditate
to try to clear my mind
so I'm not thinking about the decision
And it's interesting,
sometimes I'm meditating,
I'm meditating and the
answer just comes to me.
It's just like, you've gotta do this.
I was like oh, of course, it's obvious.
Or you sleep on it for a night or two
and then you just wake up in the morning
and was like, of course,
I've got to do this.
This is the right thing.
Everything tells me that this,
the stars are aligned here.
So there's no perfect
formula for decision-making.
It's a great question but that's my,
the best wisdom that I have
and you know, the more in life
you can perceive the grass on your side
of the fence to be greener,
the more happy you're
going to be as a person.
And I'm the king of that,
for better for worse,
almost to a fault but
I'm happy. (chuckles)
All right, let's see Ahmed?
Ahmed A.
- Hello, As-salamu alaykum everyone
and thank you so much
Sal for hosting this.
I'm delighted to be here and it's an honor
to be here with all of
you aspiring learners.
My question is about being content.
I've struggled with this contest or,
I've struggled with this concept a lot.
I think that people that aim to accomplish
shouldn't be content because being content
like, limits them to a certain extent.
What do you think about this?
Do you think that being content
is just being happy where you're at
or is it being happy along with
being or aspiring to be
more than where you're at?
- Another very good,
very deep question that,
you know, my life journey
I've had different frames of it.
I think early,
early on in my life
of when I was a lot of y'all's age,
I was very not content. (chuckles)
I had that proverbial fire in my belly.
I was constantly thinking, you know,
to Christine's last question,
how do I make the right decision?
Pick the right major?
Find the right job?
I was afraid if I'm
honest, about well what if,
what if I don't succeed?
What if I can't be in a a
solid financial position?
Many of y'all know my family, we didn't,
I was raised by a single mother.
We didn't, she worked a
lot of minimum wage jobs,
cashiers, different places,
eventually scrounged up
enough, you know, pennies to open up
a not so impressive convenience store.
So when I was a lot of
y'all's age I was just like,
and the good thing is we had a lot
of family friends who were professionals,
who were doctors, who were engineers.
And I saw how much
better your life could be
even materially but put aside what you do
in the hours of your work,
but even materially, you know,
my friends whose parents were engineers,
had nice houses in better neighborhoods.
They had health insurance.
Their path was easier.
And so I had a lot when I
was a lot of y'all's age
of angst, I could only
describe it as angst.
So like, I can't, I
need to get out of this.
I need to get some.
So that was always a bit
of a burning motivation
and I wasn't content.
And when you're not
content, it can sometimes,
I wasn't overly angsty,
I think I was a pretty.
If people knew me they would say,
oh, he's a pretty,
happy-go-lucky laid back guy
but there was a piece of me
that I would sometimes wake up
in the middle of the night it's like,
I can't, I can't,
I can't mess this up, you know.
To quote Eminem, "You only
got one shot," you know,
don't, I forgot what he said in 8 Mile
but (chuckles) it's always
there was some of that.
I think, as I've grown older,
especially I think in my thirties,
I'm now 44 going on 45.
But in my thirties I
started to realize that
that angstiness and that a little bit
of a chip on your shoulder, it's not
maybe as useful as you think it is.
It can continue to make you, once again,
you're not enjoying the
ride as much as you should
and once again, I did enjoy my ride a lot.
I had a lot of really great memories
from my journey but I think it's,
I've started to appreciate more
that I should appreciate it in the moment
while it's happening and be present
In Vedic philosophy,
there's three aspects to
everything in the universe.
The one is Sattvic, which
means truthful, you know.
Maybe you speak Urdu,
such, you know, truth
and even in actions there
can be truthful action.
The second aspect is Rajasic for those
who are familiar with the, you know,
languages from the Indian sub-continent.
You can think of Raja like a king
and Rajasic is when you're very,
it's considered a form of energy.
It's when you're very focused on,
and Rajasic action is when you're
very focused on the outcomes,
and then there's Tamasic.
Tamasic can kind of like,
you're not really in control.
It's a little bit chaotic
and you're doing something
cause you're forced.
So Sattvic action,
you're doing something because it's right
but you accept the outcome,
whatever the outcome is,
it is what it is.
You get new data points and then you make
a new set of decisions
and do what's right.
Rajasic action or Rajasic
decision-making is to say,
you know I'm gonna do
this because if I do this,
I'm gonna become rich and famous
and if I don't become rich and famous,
I'm gonna be really miserable.
Or I'm gonna do this
because if I don't do this,
something really bad's going to have.
We're not going to have enough money.
We're not gonna have food on the table.
We're not gonna do all that.
And then the Tamasic is
like I'm forced to do it.
I don't really feel like doing it
but someone's, you know, whatever.
I think we all agree that Tamasic
is not a good place to be for most,
most things in your life.
Rajasic is where most of
us are most of the time.
Most of us are saying hey, if I do this
I'm gonna get a promotion.
I'm gonna get a better job.
I'm gonna do this.
It can be very motivating
and it can give you
the external appearances of success
but, it can also make you miserable
and non-content your entire life
because no matter what,
there's going to be outcomes
that when you're in a
Rajasic frame of mind,
you have trouble accepting.
I've found that the more that I can move
to a kind of Sattvic form of action,
where I just do what is,
what I think is right at any moment.
And then whatever the outcome is,
I can just accept it and
sometimes even enjoy it
or savor it and learn from it
and then take the next set of actions.
I found that in no way does it,
does it quelch my ability to do things
or in no way, does it suppress my ability
to take action or to be ambitious
or try to do big things
but it makes me a lot more content
and a lot, frankly, a lot more pleasant
to be around (chuckles)
if I'm just accepting,
if I'm just accepting things.
And I'll say a lot of times,
I actually think you'll be more productive
if you take that Sattvic aspect
because a lot of times the Rajasic aspect,
your ego gets involved very, very heavily.
And so, you know a lot of
times I think we procrastinate
because our ego doesn't wanna realize
that it can't do the thing.
And so it's like, well oh,
maybe let me go get a snack
because your ego is
like protecting itself.
Like what if you start to study it
and you have trouble doing it,
or what if you start to write that paper
and you have writer's block.
When you have a Sattvic point of mind,
you're like, you know what,
the right thing to do
right now is just to start.
The chips will fall where they do
and so I find myself
procrastinating a lot less
when I've gotten less
caught up with the outcome
and I just wanna start,
start taking action
and then I just accept the outcome
wherever it is.
A lot of the stress at work
has gone down dramatically.
I used to you know, sometimes I have
some big decisions to make
that could affect a lot of people
and when I take the Rajasic mindset,
I'm like wow, this is the wrong decision.
It could affect these 10
people's lives, you know.
It can really stress you out.
It's not gonna help you
make a better decision.
You take a Sattvic point of view,
let me look at the data.
Let me meditate on it.
Let me take the best
possible decision I can
and look, I just have
to accept the outcome
and then let me make another
decision based on that.
But anyway, I gave you
a long-winded answer.
My apologies but
hopefully that was useful.
- All right, thank you so much.
- Great.
Let's see.
Sharvari, I don't know if,
I'm pronouncing your name correctly?
- Yeah, you are.
- Oh good.
- First of all. (chuckles)
Hi from India.
It's actually 12:45 am.
- Thank you for staying up. (laughs)
- Yeah. (chuckles)
I'm a huge fan and I just wanted to ask
that, you know we've always.
I'm a college student currently
and we've always been having so many like,
we've been getting so many tips about
how to do smart work and hard work
and how there's a difference.
And I've been using Khan
Academy for a long time
and I just wanted to know how you
would differentiate between those two?
And if you would have any
particular great tips for us
as we're making our way through college
and building a resume and, you know?
- Yeah well, I think the difference
between hard work and smart work.
I do think I was fortunate
throughout my entire academic career
that I kind of fell into what would now
be described as smart
work versus hard work
because when I was young,
I was the student that
actually in my early years,
I wasn't particularly grade motivated.
I guess I was less Rajasic
than I realized. (chuckles)
I was actually more motivated by,
hey, this is interesting,
let me connect the dots.
Okay, they're teaching me this formula
in this class but wait,
that's kind of the same formula
that we learned in the other class.
If we just changed the variables or,
if you just format the algebra
a little bit differently
and when you approach
any knowledge that way,
it naturally is going to connect more.
It's naturally going to stick more.
Some of the things I really enjoy
when I get a cover in Khan Academy
or when other people are
covering it in Khan Academy,
try to connect the dots
between different things
so they don't just feel
like things to memorize.
One, you're gonna learn it better
and life is just gonna become,
it's going to become a
lot more interesting.
In the US a lot of times they
teach the Louisiana Purchase.
Some of y'all might know about this.
You know, in 1803 Thomas Jefferson
is able to buy Louisiana from,
at the time Napoléon controlled France,
for like $3 million.
And Louisiana was not just
the State of Louisiana,
it was like a third of
what we now consider
to be the United States.
And the way they teach it
when I first learned that
I think in fifth or sixth grade,
it was kind of like they got a good deal.
Like (chuckles) you know,
that's how it's taught.
Like just memorize the fact 1803,
they bought Louisiana
and they got a good deal.
Later I learned, well the reason
why they got a good deal is that Napoléon,
who was trying to take over Europe,
had his Navy defeated at
Trafalgar by the British.
And so he really did not have
much of a Navy to speak of
and so there's no way that he
could protect this territory
that's on the other side of the planet.
And so in some ways
Napoléon got $3 million
that probably the Americans
could have just taken it
and Napoléon could have
done nothing about it
and at least he got $3 million
(chuckles) more for it.
So you know, that's just an example of
it's fun to connect
these and then when you,
when you connect it you realize,
wow, that's so interesting, right?
Like these decisions
that people are making,
very human decisions, as
opposed to just random,
random facts in history.
You know there's things that,
there's things in history or whatever,
you know, in math that
will give you goosebumps.
If you just look at them the right way.
So I try to remind everyone sometimes,
you'll hear me say this
in Khan Academy videos.
You know your biology textbook
might seem a little bit dry sometimes
or hard to read, or your stats textbook.
But that biology textbook,
like every chapter
is the culmination of probably
a few hundred people's life work.
Like you know, those
people would have done.
You know what Isaac
Newton would have done to
get his hands on your
calculus physics book
You know.
name them, Pasteur or
Curie would have done
to get their hands on
your chemistry textbook,
or to get their hands
on your biology textbook
And they really are
explaining the universe.
Sometimes they're not doing it
in the most wondrous wonder provoking way
but they are fascinating things.
So that's my you know, when you study,
when you learn things,
just try to have that air of wonder.
And when you watch a movie
like Harry Potter or something,
we all get excited because we're like,
wow, they're finding out different spells,
and they're looking at
these ancient ruins,
and they're figuring out
things about the universe
and then they're able to do magic.
And I've used learning as the same thing.
Yes, the books that you're looking at
are sometimes not the
most interesting thing
but if you really engage in it,
the way that Hermione
Granger would engage with it.
You're going to see that you're
gonna be able to do magic.
You're going to be able
to understand things
about the universe that frankly,
would have seemed like
magic even 500 years ago.
And so when you view yourself
as you're this person.
You're going on this quest.
There's things for you to explore.
Dots to connect.
It just becomes a much more
exciting, frankly experience
and then when you're
doing that the whole time.
Yes I've sometimes found
myself cramming and having to,
but even then when you're cramming,
but the knowledge is being
connected with other things,
you're more likely to learn it.
You're more likely to, retain that.
My Hermione Granger analogy
reminds me of an answer
to Christine's question
about decision-making.
Sometimes I do, and this
might be mildly delusional.
I say look, you can view yourself
as just kind of living a mundane life
or you could view
yourself as a protagonist
in an epic movie.
And whenever you're faced
with a hard decision,
you're like, well what
would the protagonist?
What would Bilbo Baggins
do, in the Hobbit?
What would Hermoine or
Harry do, in Harry Potter?
What would Hari Seldon do
in the Foundation Series?
And I find that when you do that,
first of all, life becomes a
little bit more fun to live
but you'll actually do
the more Sattvic thing.
You'll do the more like,
what would the protagonist
to do, in the story?
What would happen here to make
this a more interesting story?
And it also reminds myself the other way
that no great story is not without,
some significant stress.
You wouldn't wanna read any of these books
or watch any of these movies,
if they did not have significant stress,
and moments of tension, and
moments where you're not sure
how things are going to turn out.
So when you have those
significant stresses
or moments of tension
or times that you are
unsure of yourself, you're like oh, well,
I got a good movie that I'm living in.
Like (chuckles) my movie is interesting.
That's my best advice, stay curious.
My advice on making decisions also,
especially if you're thinking
about careers and majors.
Ask a ton of questions,
people like giving advice,
as you see, I'm enjoying
giving advice to you right now.
People, even in, I try to fundraise a lot
and someone told me this piece of advice,
which actually turned out really true.
If you ask for money,
people will give you advice.
If you ask for advice, people
give you money. (chuckles)
And it is somewhat true, but the simple,
but oftentimes the advice
is the most useful thing.
So don't be afraid to
ask as many questions.
People who are a little
bit older than you,
who've gone through this
decision making process.
You know get em one-on-one
and ask em some,
pry you know, what stresses you out?
If they're close to
you and it's not tacky,
ask em how much money they're making?
Ask em if they made the right decision?
Ask em how it's affecting other impacts
of their life, their life-work balance?
And I think that's
really going to help you
make good decisions.
I was the kid when I was in
college, I would somewhat,
I've never had a really strict filter.
I've always said what I've thought
and when I talked to people,
I've always been willing to
ask them pretty open questions.
And I think if they
realize that you're coming
from a place of vulnerability yourself
and authenticity yourself?
People will also be
vulnerable and authentic
with you and they'll give you a lot
of really good information and advice.
- That is such a great outlook.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
All right, let's go to,
Vinay.
- Hi Sal.
- Hello.
- I'm in Grade 10 and
first, thank you so, so much
like for both Khan
Academy and Schoolhouse.
Like especially for India, I'm from India
so we have the CBSE Grade 10 Board Exam.
So thank you so much like Khan Academy
really helped me a lot,
especially in these exams.
Like I'll just ask one question.
If you were 18 right now
or if you were at my age,
what would you work on and why?
Like what would you think lies ahead
in the future for the youth?
- Well I think it's gonna
be a different answer
depending on what you're interested in,
what you like, but I do think.
- The most trending thing
is that Artificial Intelligence
and the most trending part,
Artificial Intelligence,
Computer Engineering and all these things.
- If you're interested in that.
I don't think you can go wrong with it,
If you're interested in it.
I will say, you know I've
often joked, like I can meet.
I was a Computer Science,
Electrical Engineering,
Math major when I was in college.
So I was doing the equivalent of
what you're thinking about going forward
but that's because I was
really interested in it.
And when I went to college,
I thought I wanted to be
a Theoretical Physicist.
I was fascinated by theoretical physics.
So like, I wanna explain
the nature of reality
and that's what physics is after.
I was, you know I would
read Feynman's books
and look at his lectures,
and I was really inspired by that.
Then I go to college and I'm like,
even better than studying reality
is creating your own realities.
And that's what I found was interesting
about computing is that software,
especially if you thought
about virtual reality
and things like that, you
can actually create realities
and so that's what drew me to that.
So if you have a passion for that?
You have an interest for that, absolutely.
What I do recommend for everyone here,
who's roughly 18 or so years old,
is those subjects that you're learning
in your end of high school,
early college, really master them.
Master them as well as you can master them
because if you truly
master your high school,
early college level calculus,
statistics, biology, chemistry, physics,
maybe a little bit of econ.
If you truly master it,
you're going to be unstoppable
in pretty much any
field that you wanna go.
Your reading and your
writing of course, as well.
If you can write well at that level,
you're going to be unstoppable
pretty much in any field you can go in.
I'll add communications
because I think a lot
of the schoolhouse.world tutors,
they're building a muscle of communication
which is gonna be invaluable.
No one has grades on communication.
There's no standardized
test scores on communication
but the reason why schools
like MIT and UChicago
are interested in
schoolhouse.world tutors.
Is one, it shows they know the material
but it also shows that they know
how to communicate fairly,
fairly complex things.
So that's my best advice
and you'd be surprised even today,
I meet a friend who has a PhD in Biology.
They're working at a biotech farm
and they start explaining their research
and I can go surprisingly far with them.
I'm like, oh you're talking
about the Krebs cycle.
Oh, that's affecting ATP production
and they're like, how do you know this?
And I'm like, it's senior level biology
or freshmen biology in college.
And everyone learns,
everyone takes those classes
but most people cram, take the
test and then forget it all.
But I will tell you that those classes,
if you really master it,
you're going to be unstoppable
and then of course you can layer it on.
If you go into computer science
or artificial intelligence
or whatever else.
You know if I were to think about
what industries are really interesting?
Obviously artificial intelligence
is really interesting.
I think biotech is going
to be really interesting with Christopher.
I think you're going to
start seeing the intersection
of the two, where genetic engineering?
There's gonna be a lot of
ethical questions around it
but there's gonna be a lot of interesting,
positive things that can happen
for humanity there as well.
But even if you're not interested
in either of those two,
if you can speak well,
if you can write well,
if you have a solid dose
of analytical skills,
you will, you will be very relevant.
And if you take, and generally be,
if you're positive and you're authentic
and you're trying to do right
by the people around you?
And you surround yourself
with good people,
you're going to do just fine.
- Thank you so much Sal.
Hope to meet you in person on one day.
- Yeah, one day maybe.
- Yes.
It's disappointing, but yeah. (chuckles)
All right, let's see.
Okay we have, I could go
a little bit longer today.
I will, let's see Matthew.
- Thanks Sal.
This is Matt, I'm no longer a student.
Well, I am a continuous
student and I love to learn
but I actually came to ask
about schoolhouse.world.
I was wondering what you
need to reach more people
and what your like, pain
points and blockers are
for growing the business?
- Yeah, I think.
You know, schoolhouse.world is
as you know, the way that we,
the dream here, the vision here is
that we eventually are
able to make a world
where millions of people are able
to get free tutoring for everyone.
And the, I don't know it
keeps spotlighting my video.
I actually like seeing
everybody else but anyway.
The goal here is to give free tutoring,
make it for everyone.
Right now, we're at a reasonable scale.
We have several thousand
people using schoolhouse.world.
We have many hundreds of amazing tutors.
I know many of y'all are some of them
and I thank you for that.
But our hope at the schoolhouse.world team
is to just continue to scale it
because I think once we get to a scale,
that's maybe 10 times bigger
than where schoolhouse.world is right now.
Then I think the flywheel is there.
Then I think schoolhouse.world
will only grow and grow and grow.
And as y'all might appreciate,
the more tutors there are,
if we have 500 tutors now, if
we can get to 5,000 tutors.
If we have 500 sessions a week now,
if we go to 5,000 sessions a week.
Then pretty much anyone who shows up
there's probably going to be a session
on what they care about within minutes
or there might be a series, a group,
that they could join for multiple weeks
that's available very soon
and so then you have high liquidity.
I'm also hoping that,
and I've talked about this last time,
that your ability to become a tutor
and be a highly reputed tutor
actually is gonna, one, it'll feel good.
I think many of y'all enjoy doing that
but above and beyond that,
it has some cache in the broader world
that it can connect you with opportunity.
It can get you into colleges.
It can get you a job.
It can get you a scholarship.
I've talked to a major scholarship group
just day before yesterday
about exactly this.
About, and they are interested.
They are very interested if you
are a schoolhouse.world tutor,
wow, these are exactly the types
of young people that we
wanna give the scholarship to
and it's a significant scholarship
worth hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And I showed them and not
to set people's expectations
too high, I showed them some of
our highly ranked tutors who
are high school students.
And they said, wow, this is amazing.
These are exactly the type of people
that we wanna, we wanna work with.
You know my hope is, if we
go five years in the future,
we have millions of people on schoolhouse.
The quality is high.
The amazing people who are giving tutors,
many of whom who might've started
as a student trying to get tutoring,
are able to get opportunities
because they clearly
know the subject matter.
They can, they're trying
to do good for others.
And they're clearly articulate
and can explain things quite well.
So unfortunately, I
have people calling me.
I realized I did have
12:30 Pacific time booked
but I have really enjoyed this.
Sorry for the long-winded answers.
I hope they can be
vaguely useful for y'all
and I see that I'm leaving
about 30 hands raised.
My apologies for that.
What I will do, is see if we
can schedule more of these
cause I enjoyed these as well.
So don't fret if this is,
if you're enjoying this,
we will get a chance to do this again.
So I will see you all then.
Talk to y'all later, thanks for joining.
And thanks for being part of
the schoolhouse community.
- Thanks Sal.
- Have a nice day.
- Thank you so much Sal.
- Thank you.
- Thanks Sal.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah.
- Thanks Sal.
- Thank you Sal.
- All right.
- Thank you.
- Bye.
- Bye Sal.
- Thanks.
- Thank you Sal.